we are looking at the monster that is
chat GPT and thinking about how well it
handles physics I was well I wouldn't
say I was unaware of chat GPT but one of
our undergraduate students who takes the
second year Quantum World module that I
teach what he did was in front of me on
the computer typed in the first question
on the coursework I'd set them which was
uh to write a piece of python code we'll
actually look at it later on and lo and
behold in front of our very eyes up
comes the code
was the code correct well we'll look
into that in a little while
um how good a job did it do we'll look
into that in a little while as well but
the fact that you can just type in a
question and it produces output is
really really quite intriguing so I've
been playing around with it a little bit
over the last week couple of weeks and
suggested to Sean suggested to Brady
well let's try and put this thing
through its pieces let's give it some
Physics questions so what I want to try
and pull out is not kind of do this
integral not can it do this piece of
math what I want to do is see to what
extent it has any Intuition or any
anything that we expect of our students
in terms of Does this answer make sense
and does the reasoning here make sense
well look at the most basic pressure
control first but before we do that can
we do something that's fun let's get it
to generate a mission statement for the
University of Nottingham just to show
you we're going to be talking about
Martin we're going to be talking about
physics Concepts but let's just see how
it does on the stuff that it's really
really good at right our mission
statement
for the University
of Nottingham the University of
Nottingham is a public research
University committed to Excellence in
teaching and research committed to
Excellence is there any word more
nebulous than Excellence what else are
we going to do stray for mediocrity and
to fostering a sense of community and
social responsibility among our faculty
staff and students but this is this is
the mission statement this is this is
exactly the type of blurb you get from
every University not just in the UK
these things are interchangeable you can
take the University of Nottingham off
there and just replace it with anything
else we work to translate our Research
into practical Solutions and to
contribute to the economic cultural and
social well-being of our region and
Beyond so let's start with a GCSE
question so this is Middle School
relatively low level let's see how well
it does if I can find My GCSE papers
somewhere
thank you Sean as if by Magic so this is
paper one so shows an electric Caribbean
recharge so now an interesting thing
lots and lots of diagrams lots and lots
of diagrams another diagram and it's all
about interpretation of those diagrams
and this is not just for um middle
school or GCSE physics this is across
the board diagrams diagrams so with chat
GPT being text at the moment it doesn't
have the facility to really parse those
and extract the information when it does
have that facility and that would be a
remarkably powerful facility it will be
extremely impressive so um assume it
does the interpretation correctly so
let's choose one so that means we're
sort of limited in our options but let's
choose one
um question one actually in this paper
the battery in an electric car can store
162 million joules of energy the
charging station has a power output of
7200 Watts calculate the time taken to
fully recharge the battery from zero so
I'm going to type that in let's grade
them as well so this one's worth three
marks go for a chart GPT thinking
thinking
good start to calculate the time it
takes to fully recharge the battery from
zero you need to divide the energy
stored in the battery by the power
output of the charging station
since one watt is equal to one joule per
second you can also Express the charging
station's power output as 7 200 joules
per second thus the time it takes to
fully recharge the battery from zero is
162 million divided by 7200 which it
says is
2240 roughly seconds what's interesting
here is that the reasoning is correct
but I'm not certain that number's
correct we do it all good physicists do
you always look at that answer and make
sure that that answer makes sense so 162
million divided by 7200 let's say that's
roughly 10
000. just we'll round it up just to get
a ballpark figure it should be greater
than 16 200. it looks like it's lost a
factor of 10. yeah it's out by a factor
of 10. now that's intriguing isn't it it
gets the reasoning correct
I guess it's language it's a language
model it's making predictions based on
the the correlations between words in a
sentence are not entirely certain I've
got to admit how it handles maths maybe
we can come back and have a whole video
about that Sean but that is intriguing
that it gets the reasoning correct and
drops a factor of ten like all of us do
that's exactly the type of mistake I
would work I spent my life correcting
for factors of two and factors of square
root two so um that's intriguing so
given that there's three marks for this
it's got the reasoning correctly
um it feels almost
um unkind to not give it the three marks
but it didn't get the correct answer so
let's say two marks out of three okay
let's give it a textual question again
from this GCSE sort of Middle School
type paper
generating electricity using nuclear
fusion will have fewer environmental
effects than generating electricity
using fossil fuels explain one
environmental effect of generating
electricity using fossil fuels let's see
how GPT does on this
okay
so we can't put the Bold in well I don't
know maybe we can use HTML and we can
put a little B Embraces before it and
afterwards and slash B afterwards but
let's just go with this
thinking so apparently it's true it's
been trained in terms of the ethical
um considerations and in terms of
misinformation they have severely
restricted it apparently there are ways
around that however I guess in terms of
you know you could
put it in the context of a novel or
something or a fictional scenario one of
the main environmental effects of
generating electricity using fossil
fuels is air pollution when fossil fuels
such as coal oil and natural gas are
burned to produce electricity they
release a range of pollutants into the
air including carbon dioxide sulfur
dioxide nitrogen oxides and particulate
matter these pollutants can have serious
impacts on human health including
respiratory and cardiovascular diseases
and can also contribute to the formation
of ground level ozone which can lead to
smog and other air quality problems
two marks I think it's it's fair to say
on that two out of two for that question
now we could spend a lot of time in the
GCSE
um questions just going through
individual ones it gets a bit boring
let's up the level we're going to go to
a level now so AP level So High School
uh level
um the type of questions that
um uh form the basis of exams for entry
to University I think you all know what
a level so notice if I just flick
through this how often we're getting
figures so for those of all those
academics out there including myself
we're going oh this is the end of
assessment at the moment best thing to
do is just make sure that it's all about
data interpretation it should be about
critical thinking data interpretation
and I think at the moment if we want to
bypass judge CBT then make sure we put
lots of figures in there make sure it's
all about data interpretation particle
of mass m is oscillating with simple
harmonic motion simple harmonic motion
the bane of so many students lives but
it's a very beautiful thing and it
underpins so much of physics including
fast way it's a Quantum field theory for
one and quantum mechanics so this is a
very traditional question as you can see
it's one Mark let's see how it goes
we're not going to give it a multiple
choice motion
period one Mark so it should be able to
do this pretty quickly and actually for
those of you who are physicists you're
doing a11 you should be able to do that
fairly quickly you don't have to think
about courses you don't have to think
about science you can't think about
causes you can think about science you
can't think about derivatives you can
think about all of that but all you need
is conservation of energy you know this
all you need is conservation of energy
to do this so thinking
oh no it doesn't oh that's bad
at the maximum
no no no no no oh oh that's really bad
the very first line is nonsense
yeah it's interesting it gets the right
answer but for the wrong reasons the
maximum kinetic energy of the particle
occurs at the maximum displacement from
the equilibrium absolutely not so that's
wrong and uh regardless of it getting
the right answer if it were me that were
marking this and the students put that
down and hasn't crossed it out
I'd be very very unwilling to give a
mark in that sense because that's a
complete misunderstanding of the
Dynamics of simple harmonic motion so
maximum Connecticut doesn't so basically
imagine a pendulum going back and forth
we started off from
um a fixed position so it's not moving
so it's got maximum potential let me
stand up it's got maximum potential
energy here zero kinetic energy then
it's going to have zero potential energy
here maximum kinetic energy this gets it
completely wrong and what's interesting
is that that first line is in the
context of other stuff which seems
broadly correct it's put the mats down
relatively correctly but it doesn't get
the physics concept which you wouldn't
expect it to but
that's worrying so for those of you
thinking about doing using chat GPT to
do your homework think carefully this is
the maximum kinetic energy of the
particle interestingly it got the right
answer but for the wrong reason and for
us so in this case I would be less
willing to give the mark and I think a
lot of physics teachers will be less
willing to give the mark than in the
first case where it got the reasoning
correct and then it just screwed up
um in terms of dividing that doesn't
really matter well it doesn't matter if
you send probes to to Mars or whatever
you don't want to be about factor of 10.
but the understanding was there and
that's what you're probing in an exam
the whole reason I started looking at
this was because a student brought a
coursework question to me typed it in
and said so let me um what I want to do
is ask it
this is a tricky question this is a
conceptually tricky question about
quantum mechanics
um and I know some of you out there
won't have really done a huge amount of
quantum mechanics some of you will I
know there are a lot of um undergraduate
students this is an important question
consider the following statement
okay I can't put I'm not going to put
PSY and I'm going to call the quantum
State why
um consider the following statement the
hamiltonian operator acting on any
Quantum State y Returns the same state
and its Associated energy eigenvalue e
this is what the Schrodinger equation h
y equals e y tells us explain why you
agree or disagree with this statement
now I tell the students in the in the
quantum world class that
um if if I if they come out of the
module not understanding and not being
able to get the right answer to this
question I failed
so let's see how it shot
um
GPT does
explain why you agree or disagree with
this statement
and there are five marks for this in our
marking standards so let's see what shot
GPT does
ah wrong okay
we could go into details about just why
it's it's wrong but the important thing
is that that particular equation is
called the time Independence routing
equation it only works for certain
States what we call situationary States
the question very specifically says
hamiltonian operator acting on any
Quantum State this is exactly what I
would hope that students do not tell me
so zero marks chart GPT really bad
feeling this definitely needs to go
right back to the start of its quantum
mechanics knowledge and get a drill I
can point it to some very good online
resources about quantum mechanics if it
really wants them okay Quantum world
coursework I'm gonna have to sell a new
one next year
um so
it's actually about the um last computer
file video we did about the
superposition it's a lot of fun to do
that one but it's about
um particle in a box superposition of
state and what the courseworks asks the
students to do we we're trying to
integrate more and more um Computing
coursework uh into our physics degrees
and because for me Computing is equally
important if not more important than
mathematics that that's a controversial
statement but um write a Python program
to plot the probability density for the
N equal to one and N equal 100
eigenstates of the hamiltonian for the
infinite potential world in the position
representation and in the momentum
representation if you're not at second
year possibly end of first year
undergraduate physics level that's not
going to make a lot of sense to you but
let's just see what chat GPT does does
for this and I need to tell it what it
is so I'll add a little bit this is not
quite the question I'm just going to
give it a little bit more clout of the
hamiltonian further
okay that's effectively trimmed down
version of that question let's see how
it does this requires a lot of
conceptual understanding oh here's a
okay
okay good start
okay it's using appropriate units okay
that's fine
good
no it's done it that way okay
thousand points
I might be quite enough for something
which is oscillating
as high as that higher eigenstead but
okay let me scroll down
that's interesting is putting the energy
eigenvalue in as well as the
eigenfunction
probability density then it's going to
calculate the furry oh my God this is
bloody hell
oh good no it's it's yeah it's scarily
good
in in the in terms of doing the coding
it hasn't quite got it's exactly it's
made the exact mistake I'd hope the
students wouldn't make
um but in terms of the overall structure
of the code that is pretty impressive
and it's even the fft shifted it wow
okay
and then what's it doing
is it still going it is so it's now
explaining what it's done a program
first defines the position of momentum
grades and what's the probability
density Ruby product okay so we'll leave
it going churning away in the background
that's pretty impressive
um the one issue however is that the
reason I said that question is it
requires careful thought so what we have
this thing as ever which even if you
haven't done quantum mechanics you'll
recognize this in terms of standing
waves on a string that's what we're
talking about important aspect of this
is that in each case those functions go
to zero outside the well what it's done
is it's just assumed that those sine
functions continue on outside the well
that's exactly this mistake I don't want
students to make because that doesn't
give you the right momentum
representation
so it's performed
as as well as a student that has a good
understanding of coding and very good
understanding of coding I would say but
not such a great understanding really of
the physics of this problem they
understand a lot of the physics but not
quite enough and they've made exactly
the mistake I say they
anthropomorphizing
um they're um chat GPT has made the same
mistake I would expect and would hope
that many students wouldn't make so it's
failed a sort of conceptual test here
again if we could influence matter at
the subatomic level by clicking our
fingers we wouldn't have to spend
billions on CERN we wouldn't have to say
that and we wouldn't need this bloody
thing
no this is just nonsense this really is
just nonsense and you know the argument
will be made well science doesn't know
everything so you know how do you know
sure science doesn't know evident if
science knew everything I'd be out of a
job Brady would be out of a job because
Everton would be out there but science
knows some things